okay you I'm going to just say things
okay but we are here at the World
Economic Forum in mumbai india and is
exciting to see that this very
prestigious forum has come to india and
mumbai being the financial capital of
india it is important that it is held
here and it is not a good interaction
that is going on and what not I would
say that clearly India is one of the
fastest-growing GDP is in the world
today with that India has its own status
because today if you look at West Europe
is not doing very well the banks are in
difficult situation countries are in
difficult situation you look at United
States it's still doing great not great
but okay at best and Asia is the one who
is going to lead us around with that in
mind if you look at potential business
of fortune it is potential partnership
opportunities this is the place to be
and within that Mumbai is the place to
be now in many of the states that we
work with clearly Mirage fries are very
friendly environment wherein they want
people to come in and invest and we
going are actually investing in
maharashtra we have a maintenance repair
and overall facility not work which has
started construction earlier this year
in which will be completed by the end of
next year and we're going to spend about
five hundred crows in doing that similar
to that of course major customers of
going like air india and jet airways our
house right here and mumbai is one of
the largest traffic carrier cities in
india so I think the World Economic
Forum is at the right place at the right
position and I think leaders that are
here are going to be excited to see
even more potential so they can come and
invest more in Maharashtra in India and
really reap the benefits of